you want to know what takes real courage
your murderous friends we're survivors
or anyone elses palm sweaty I mean mine
is because of my condition but that
trailer was insane
have you finished binge watching house
of cards yet are you devastated that you
have to wait another year for more
President Frank Underwood with good news
we've compiled our favorite things about
house of cards and Frank into one video
and even better news it's the video
you're watching right now I'm drew
Coolidge and this is hashtag news
poorni there are season 1 through 3 mild
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
those yet get out of here go I'm talking
about you leave ok it's just the cool
people left let's do this right
Underwood is the coldest most dangerous
by sexiest president we've ever had
since Martin Van Buren in his latest
season front takes the reins of America
and has to add international mind games
to his political hustle Frank is a
genuine certified grade-a American
badass from his cuff links to his
penchant for confusing tables for doors
to peeing on his own father's grave of
course is gentle but Stern Southern
drawl I've always loathed the necessity
of sleep there are two types of vice
presidents doormats and Matadors which
do you think I intend to be Frank is a
real go-getter just look at all this
planning and scheming Jesus I want to
believe your Prentice
in fact a lot of house of cards is based
on real-life political drama Frank isn't
the first politician to have killed
someone and remained in office
US Representative William Gray is killed
opposing congressman Jonathan kilee in a
duel in 1838 and just like Frank
Underwood didn't do any jail time for it
but Frank's a good guy I mean he makes
you feel included in the show did you
think I'd forgotten you nobody has made
us feel so much a part of their show
since Zack Morris would timeout reality
on Saved by the Bell
timeout yeah this is horrible Frank
Underwood would be nothing without his
Queen Clare Lannisters we are trying to
help junk clan do not talk to my wife
that way do not mistake any history you
have shared for the slightest
understanding of what our marriage is
but their relationship is best described
as open
even the Russian president knows about
it I was crazy right
but the real romance of this show is
Frank and Freddie just look at these two
cuties well there's something different
about these ribs I didn't think they
could get any better but these was
something special well try the new
butcher slow bleeds is home today legal
but well I won't tell
well scenes always make my mouth water
what do you think I've met the men I did
well that's it for hashtag news thanks
for watching guys honestly I appreciate
it if you want to keep watching
subscribe comment with your favorite
moments from house a car and share it
with your friends I'm drew Coolidge and
I know who I'll be voting for in 2016 fu
fu fu
fu that's his initials